I haven't come alone yet
, but I want to say hello This time, I'm in bad shape
.
Well, I'm just a captain
right away.
Hey, don't
put your clothes on, no, get off, you know,
ball and punctuality are the basics of dying, but
you're in
trouble.  I
think I'm one of them. I'll bring back the moonlight egg flowers that grow on the top of this mountain.
Did you call me out of the
blue
just for that reason? It seems that the moonlight egg only blooms once every four years and only for a short period of time when the full moon rises.
However,
it seems that moonlight orchids can also be used as medicine and are
sold at high prices, so it seems that
this mountain has been managed by the locals so that it will not be destroyed
.  Thieves might attack Gekko Ran
already, eh, that guy has a mysterious arm.
I'll bring
you a guide.